es ist ein guter tag für europa dass der
bundeskanzler scholz heute morgen
bereits mitgeteilt als wir aller ist die
welt aufgewacht ist und es war klar es
gibt einen krieg jetzt hat er sich
wieder an uns gewandt an uns alle an uns
deutsche gewand mit einer
fernsehansprache die wir ihnen jetzt
hier zeigen wollen
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
heute ist ein furchtbarer tag für die
ukraine und ein düsterer tag für europa
wir alle sorgen und zum den frieden
ich kann mir gut vorstellen welche
fragen sie sich heute abend stellen hier
geht es da nicht anders die lage ist
sehr ernst
gerade erleben wir den beginn eines
krieges wie wir in europa so seit mehr
als 75 jahren nicht erlebt haben
russlands präsident putin hat die
entscheidung getroffen die ukraine
militärisch anzugreifen
das ist ein überfall auf ein
unabhängiges souveränes land er ist
durch nichts und durch niemanden zu
rechtfertigen es ist der versuch grenzen
innerhalb europas gewaltsam zu
verschieben ja vielleicht ein ganzes
land von der weltkarte zu tilgen
voller absicht recht präsident putin mit
den grundprinzipien der charta der
vereinten nationen und mit der
europäischen friedensordnung
er gefährdet das leben unzähliger
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine dem
bruder volk russlands all das geschieht
nicht weit weg von uns sondern hier in
europa gerade zwei flugstunden von
berlin entfernt sitzen moment familien
in luftschutzkellern
frauen männer und kinder bangen um ihr
leben
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bewaffnen
sich um ihre heimat gegen eine
invasionsarmee zu verteidigen
in diesen schweren stunden sind unsere
gedanken bei den tapferen bürgern und
bürgern der ukraine
ich habe präsident zielinski heute
morgen in einem telefonat gesagt das
ukrainische volk und seine frei gewählte
regierung haben unsere volle solidarität
diese verletzung der souveränität der
ukraine durch russland werden wir nicht
hin
mit dem angriff auf die ukraine
präsident putin die zeit zurückdrehen
aber es gibt kein zurück in die zeit des
19 jahrhunderts als großmächte über die
köpfe kleinere staaten hinweg
entschieden
es gibt kein zurück in die zeit des
kalten krieges als supermächte die welt
unter sich aufteilten einflusszonen und
es gibt auch kein zurück in die zeit vor
1989 damals erkämpften die bürgern und
bürger in mittel und osteuropa sich ihre
freiheit und demokratie auch in unserem
land und in der ukraine
deshalb haben wir präsident putin wieder
und wieder vor einem krieg gegen die
ukraine gewarnt
noch vor einer woche habe ich persönlich
mehrere stunden mit ihm im kreml
diskutiert und ihm klar gesagt dieser
krieg wäre ein schwerer fehler er würde
damit auch dem russischen volk und der
zukunft seines eigenen landes schweren
schaden zufügen
präsident putin hat all die warnung und
bemühungen um einen diplomatischen
ausweg in den wind geschlagen er allein
nicht das russische volk hat sich für
diesen krieg entschieden er allein trägt
dafür die volle verantwortung
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
abermals appelliere ich mit allem
nachdruck an präsident putin stellen sie
die kampfhandlung unverzüglich ein
ziehen sie die russischen truppen aus
der ukraine zurück wieder rufen sie die
völkerrechtswidrige anerkennung der
gebiete donetsk und lohans bis zuletzt
haben wir in der internationalen
gemeinschaft auf dialog gesetzt und das
gespräch mit moskau gesucht wir hatten
hoffnung aber wir waren nicht naiv
deshalb haben wir uns parallel auf
diesen ernstfall vorbereitet mit unseren
verbündeten und partnern in der
europäischen union in der nato und in
der g 7 haben wir uns auf ein ganzes
paket von wirtschaftssanktionen
verständigt unser ziel der russischen
führung klar zu machen für diese
aggression wird sie einen hohen preis
zahlen
nach der anerkennung der gebiete don
jetzt und nur hans durch russland haben
der erste sanktionen erlassen und wir
haben die zertifizierung der gaspipeline
nord stream zwei ausgesetzt
angesichts des heutigen überfalls auf
die ukraine verhängen wir weitere
tiefgreifende sanktionen sie werden die
russische wirtschaft hart treffen
gleichzeitig müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass dieser konflikt nicht auf weitere
länder europas übergreift ich bin mir
mit dem amerikanischen präsidenten und
unseren europäischen freunden einig dies
mit allen uns zur verfügung stehenden
mitteln zu verhindern
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
deutschland und seine verbündeten wissen
sich zu schützen
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger wir
sind entschlossen und handeln
geschlossen darin liegt unsere stärke
als freie demokratie
putin wird nicht gewinnen die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der ukraine
wollen demokratie und freiheit und
europas zukunft mit einer zukunft in
frieden und freiheit seien
dafür werden wir sorgen gemeinsam mit
unseren freunden und partnern